what are your thoughts on cellular
automata and the game of life
have you ever played with those kind of
little uh games i think uh the game of
life uh it is
is wonderful and uh
uh
and
and shows all kind of
stuff about how things
can evolve without the creator
understanding
anything more than
the power of learning things in a way
but to me the most
important thing about the game of life
is that is is how it
focused for me
what what it meant to have free will or
not
because the game of life is obviously
totally deterministic yes and i i i find
it hard to believe that anybody who's
ever had children
cannot believe in free will right on the
other hand
this makes it crystal clear
john conway said
he wondered whether it was
immoral to shut the computer off after
he got into a particularly interesting
play of the game of life
um wow yeah so there is
to me the reason i love the game of life
is exactly as you said a clear
illustration that from
simple initial conditions with simple
rules you know exactly how the system is
operating is deterministic
and yet if you let yourself
if if you allow yourself to
lose that knowledge a little bit
enough to see the bigger organisms
that emerge and then all of a sudden
they seem conscious they seem uh not
conscious but living if if the universe
is finite
we're all living in the game of life to
slow down i mean
it's sped up a lot
but do you think technically
some of the ideas that you used for
analysis of algorithms can be used to
analyze the game of life
can we make sense of it or is it too
weird yeah i mean i i
i've got i've got a dozen exercises in
volume
for
fascicle 6 uh
that
actually worked rather well for that
purpose
but
bill gospers
came up with the
with the algorithm that that allows
that allowed golly to uh to
you know to run thousands and thousands
of times faster
you know the website called golly
g-o-l-l-y it simulates the cellular
automata like game of life yeah you got
you got to check it out yeah
can i ask you about john conway
yes in fact i i i'm just reading now the
the issue of mathematical intelligence
or that came in last last week it's a
whole issue devoted to to
uh uh you know
remembrance of of him
did you know him
i
i still slept overnight in his house
several times i
yeah he recently passed away
yeah he got he died a year ago
may
i think it was i've covered
what do you what are some memories of
him of his work that stand out for you
is did uh
on a technical level did any of his work
inspire you on a personal level that
did he himself inspire you in some way
and you know absolutely all of those
things but
let's see when did i first meet him i
guess i first met him at oxford in like
1967 when i was
okay that's a long time ago yeah yeah
you were minus
20 years old or something i don't know
1967.
but but uh
there was a conference where
uh
and i think i spoke
i was speaking about
something that
known as the canoes bendix algorithm now
but but he
he gave it famous talk about knots
and and at the end i didn't know at the
time but but
anyway that talk had now
the source of thousands and thousands of
papers citizens since then
uh and
it was he was reported on something that
he had done
in high school
you know
almost 10 years earlier
[Music]
before this conference but he never
published it and and he climaxed his
talk by
building some nasty
you have these lit these little plastic
things that you that you could stick
together uh it's it's it's
it's something like lego but easier
and so he made a whole bunch of knots in
front of the audience and so on and then
disassembled it
so it was
a dramatic lecture
before he had learned how to give even
more dramatic lectures later
so
you